ja dieses buch mein neues buch über
tesla sollte nicht erscheinen wenn es
nach der deutschen autolobby gegangen
wäre und das zeigt wie hier in
deutschland immer noch man muss sagen
gegen den technologischen fortschritt
gegen die wissenschaft intrigiert wird
heute erscheint also tesla oder wie
allen masc die elektromobilität
revolutioniert und ich lasse mal wieder
dampf ab wir gehen direkt in die vollen
los geht's herzlich willkommen
wenn ich ein ganz normaler autor gewesen
wäre dann würde es mein neues buch nicht
oder zumindest so nicht geben wenn ich
jetzt nicht selbst erheblich ins risiko
gegangen wäre dem druck von 10.000
büchern das lektorat gestaltung cover
vertrieb und so weiter finanziert hätte
dann gäbe es dieses buch wahrscheinlich
so nicht wenn ich also nicht etwas
zurück gelegt hätte und da reingesteckt
hätte würde diese recherche kaum an die
öffentlichkeit kommt ich werde euch also
sehr dankbar wenn ihr wenn euch das
thema interessiert das buch besorgen
würde damit diese informationen auch in
die welt getragen werden
mehr infos dazu gibt's hier unterm und
bitte geht in die buchhandlung und
bestellt es dort ich habe keine vertrieb
dh dass die buchhandlung noch ein wenig
darauf gestoßen werden müssen danke also
für jede unterstützung die von euch
kommt das ist ein thema an dem mir sehr
viel liegt und über die
falschinformationen und unwahrheiten
über die elektromobilität müssen die
leute unbedingt aufgeklärt werden also
umso mehr dieses buch verbreitet wird
desto besser ist es für die
elektromobilität aber für diese
ablehnende haltung gegenüber meinem buch
braucht es keine verschwörung oder sonst
irgendetwas obskures das sind ganz
normale mechanismen und es hat auch mit
wissenschaft vielleicht mehr im bereich
psychologie oder soziologie zu tun und
welche das sind welche eigenschaften
welche phänomene das sind das kann ich
ein wenig nachvollziehen weil ich selbst
auch als motorjournalist bei auto motor
und sport tv auf vox gearbeitet habe
also für dieses buch für dieses buch
habe ich intensiv recherchiert und
ziemlich verblüffende informationen rund
um die elektromobilität und tesla
zusammen getragen
auf den punkt gebracht hier wird
technologie eingesetzt um ein großes
problem den klimawandel zumindest
zu mildern technologie im einsatz für
ökologie und genau das will wohl kaum
jemand in der autobranche höheren
sinngemäß schrieb mir der verlag mit dem
ich einen buchvertrag für dieses buch
hatte als verlag der große deutsche
autokonzerne zu seinen kunden zählt
können wir ein buch in dem die these
vertreten wird dass tesla ökologie und
technologie zusammen bringt nicht
veröffentlichen
das saß die diskussion hängte sich dann
immer wieder an fakten auf und dass
diese nicht korrekt sein und da kommen
wir auf das schwierige thema von
alternativen fakten fake news usw
aber und das ist die gute erkenntnis am
ende wird da nichts unklar oder man
könnte es irgendwie diskutieren es
bleibt dabei und da fühle ich mich in
meiner argumentation aus den letzten
jahren absolut bestätigt wissenschaft
oder nicht wissenschaft wissenschaft
oder erfahrungswissen also praktische
erfahrung das sind zwei verschiedene
paar schuhe
es zeigt sich eben auch hier wieder
ausschließlich wissenschaft mit ihren
methoden und verfahren ist in der lage
wirklich klarheit und vor allem wahrheit
zu bringen erfahrung ist ja oft
anekdotisch also es sind
zusammengetragene einzelne erzählung die
nicht unbedingt zur aufklärung beitragen
sie können prima dazu beitragen in diese
richtung zu forschen aber eben erst die
forschung die wissenschaftliche
methodische behandlung kann aufklären
und sorgt für belege oder eben die
journalistische aber gründliche und
umfassende recherche und ehrlich gesagt
ich habe diese fakten diskussion gar
nicht verstanden also mit dem verlag bis
ich dann ja bis ich dann einen motor
journalisten als lektor engagiert habe
er steht mit einem pseudonym im
impressum wer angst hat mit dem buch in
verbindung gebracht zu werden so viel
schon mal dazu und mit ihm dürfte ich
dann die fakten diskutieren denn auch er
war bei dem einen oder anderen fakt
anderer meinung zwei beispiel beim
ersten geht es um den schwerpunkt eines
fahrzeugs dazu muss ich kurz ins buch
gehen denn da habe ich beim vergleich
zwischen elektroauto und verbrenner mal
angenommen
das elektroauto sei die übliche
antriebsart und jetzt sollen autos mit
verbrennungsmotor eingeführt werden na
ja bei dieser betrachtungsweise kommen
verbrenner gar nicht gut weg und ein
punkt ist eben der schwerpunkt umso
tiefer der nämlich
desto schwerer kann etwas umkippen oder
beim auto sich überschlagen und bei
tesla ist das wirklich ein problem da
die batterie zwischen den beiden achsen
am tiefsten punkt des fahrzeugs
abgesehen von den rädern liegt haben die
fahrzeuge dem am tiefsten liegenden
schwerpunkt von allen pkw da ist physik
halt unabänderlich da kann man nicht
drüber diskutieren der schwerpunkt ist
so niedrig dass die fahrzeuge bei den
tests wo sie sich überschlagen sollten
das einfach nicht tun sie kippen nicht
um beim verbrennen ist das natürlich
anders da motor getriebe tank und so
weiter und so fort aufgrund ihres
volumens nicht so tief jedenfalls sich
komplett so tief im fahrzeug liegen
können bzw also nur ein teil ihres
volumens kann wenn sie ganz tief
montiert sind da unten liegen aber ein
großteil ihres volumens liegt halt
darüber über den achsen das ist halt
physik sprich grundsätzlich kippen
verbrenner leichter um als elektroautos
punkt mit meinem lektor muss sich über
dieses konstruktionsprinzip tatsächlich
diskutieren
das ist aber ein unumstößlicher fakt und
ja vielleicht kippt ein super flacher
bugatti nicht so leicht um wie ein
elektro suv aber es geht um das
konstruktionsprinzip und nicht um
exotische ausnahme
ausnahmen bestätigen ja auch bekanntlich
die regel und dieses prinzip ist
unumstößlich fakt oder beispiel 2 was
brennt leichter ein verbrenner oder ein
elektroauto
kleiner tipp des rätsels lösung ist in
der bezeichnung versteckt dazu muss man
wissen dass es bei tessa tatsächlich ein
brand problem gab dass ich im buch
ausführlich schildere nur konnte es
inzwischen gelöst werden verbrenner
fahrzeuge enthalten aber brennbare
flüssigkeiten und das in erheblichen
mengen und die geraten halt dann gerne
mal zum beispiel bei einem unfall in
brand da berichtet halt niemand drüber
war das absolut normal ist da wundert
sich niemand drüber und so brennan
verbrenner halt deutlich öfter
ehrlicherweise muss man dazu sagen dass
es hier noch keine studien dazu gibt
aber statistiken und der gesamtverband
der deutschen versicherungswirtschaft
fast aus den vorliegenden daten zusammen
dass die brandlast bei verbrennern höher
ist als bei elektrofahrzeugen durch die
berichterstattung der letzten jahre hat
sich allerdings in
öffentlichkeit und beim motor
journalisten das bild verfestigt dass
elektroautos öfter brennen aber das ist
jetzt ganz konkret anekdotisch weil es
immer nur an einzelfällen aufgegangen
wird und wenn man das recherchiert und
die daten dazu zusammen trägt dann zeigt
sich ein realistisches bild laut einer
quelle im buch brennen verbrenner
übrigens 45 mal öfter auf die gefahrene
strecke gerechnet als elektrofahrzeuge
also das hat nichts damit zu tun dass es
mehr verbrenner gibt als
elektrofahrzeuge
nein auf die gefahrene strecke
umgerechnet ist also eigentlich ganz gut
verständlich warum hier zum einen
kollegen aus ihren erfahrungen schöpfen
und fakten in zweifel ziehen
und es ist ja auch die pflicht von
journalisten und journalistinnen ihre
erfahrung dazu zu nutzen quellen und
informationen in frage zu stellen wenn
sie dann allerdings widerlegt werden
dann sollte man das auch zur kenntnis
nehmen und seine erfahrung dann
dementsprechend korrigieren und das ist
so ein generelles problem manche leute
neigen dazu sich festzulegen und dann
keine mühe mehr von ihrem einmal
bezogenen standpunkt abzuweichen
und genau das ist menschlich und
verständlich aber es ist nicht
professionell und das gilt leider bei
vielen für das thema elektromobilität
und zb konkret für den co2 rucksack oder
die rohstoffe für die batterie da wird
eine menge mist verzapft und selbst
angesehene persönlichkeiten lassen sich
davon den karren spannen
ich habe all diese themen sorgfältig und
ausführlich recherchiert es gibt ein
umfangreiches quellenverzeichnis und
nichts bleibt im unklaren oder ich ziehe
schräge vergleich aber ich freue mich
also wirklich riesig wenn er das buch zu
stellen würde wenn es euch interessiert
es für eine sache die möglich sehr am
herzen liegt die elektromobilität und
wir in berlin oder in der nähe wohnt der
kann am samstag den 17
ein signiertes exemplar bekommen auf der
elbe auf 20 21 auf dem euref campus in
berlin
da geht es rund um die elektromobilität
und fahrerinnen und fahrer von
elektroautos stellen ihre fahrzeuge
interessierten vor für euch spezielle
habe ich hier unter dem link einen
gratis futter bekommt der kostenlosen
eintritt ich freue mich auf jeden und
jede die oder der kommt also bis dann
bleibt dran